it is day two of the World Cup in Qatar
and while the games are well underway
it's what's happening off the pitch
that's making headlines the captains of
several European teams were planning on
playing with armband supporting
diversity and inclusion in a gesture
seen as a rebuke to katara's Human
Rights record but FIFA wouldn't have it
the governing body threatened players
with on-field punishment a risk they
knew would be too great for the athletes
to take
England Wales and Germany were three of
the seven European national teams who
wanted to set an example for tolerance
and inclusion with a rainbow-themed
armband and the statement one love FIFA
saw things differently while not
expressly Banning the armbands FIFA said
referees would sanction players who wore
them with a yellow card the Fifa Fifa
today banned a statement in favor of
diversity and human rights these are
values to which it commits itself in its
own statues this is more than
frustrating from our point of view
FIFA got their way and the evidence was
on the arm of England Captain Harry Kane
it appears that no European nation wants
to risk a yellow card to make a
political statement
and for more on this we can bring in
Mustafa qadri he's a specialist in human
rights and labor rights welcome to the
day Mr carty first it was supposed to be
a rainbow Armin then the teams bound to
pressure and decided on a one love
armband for diversity and inclusion now
I think they've settled on one reading
no discrimination why did FIFA raise the
stakes for players wanting to take a
stand at the World Cup
well I think to be honest firstly thank
you for having me on your show and for
raising these issues it's very important
I think frankly it's Death By A Thousand
Cuts what we've seen is backtracking by
FIFA and let's face it those behind them
which is the football associations the
teams and corporate sponsors uh towards
Qatar to effectively not address the
human rights issues in that country and
instead everyone else compromising for
them so really it's quite disappointing
but the other thing that's most
important is the signal it sends to the
lgbti community and did anyone facing
human rights issues not just in Qatar
not just in the region but globally you
have this very powerful prominent
players you know giving into this and of
course for FIFA itself that claims to be
a force for good respecting human rights
it sends the worst possible signal at
the very beginning of the tournament you
see you're disappointed but are you
surprised at all that the players aren't
willing to sacrifice their success in
order to make a statement
yeah it's a really good question so
obviously you know you could say it's
the World Cup players work very hard to
get to this very moment but then you
know it's such an interesting situation
we have where in the same game with the
Iranian team where players in that team
are probably risking their lives there's
probably a huge risk of you know serious
human rights abuse on them from the
Iranian authorities for being so I think
Brave and outspoken about the genuine
human rights crisis in Iran you
juxtapose that with the millionaire
footballs and the England team where
they don't seem to be able to go that
far of course you know I think it's
unfair to dump everything on the England
football team there's a deeper Point
here how did we get to this point how
did it we allow Qatar to be having this
world cup without adequate checks and
requirements on it to respect its human
rights responsibilities the thing that
viewers really need to understand is
that Qatar has ratified meaning it's
basically a codified into law some of
the most significant human rights
treaties in the world so that
International Covenant on civil and
political rights you know conventions
against discrimination so there's a hard
law requirements on Qatar and therefore
FIFA to respect human rights so yes
absolutely is a question that has to be
asked about these England football
players but there's a wider Community
here that's had 12 years to address this
issue and they clearly haven't and I
think that's the thing we really need to
be focusing on
are we in too deep right now is the
football community so broken that we
can't recover from something like this
or is there a way forward
it's a very good question so I think
when you work at human rights as I do
you're always inherently an optimistic
person and you know as Humanity you know
we've dealt with lots of huge challenges
um in human history including in Germany
so I do believe we can address this but
the only way we can address this is
through an honest discussion it starts
with things like the process through
which FIFA selects hosts for this
tournament having very robust human
rights requirements that also apply to
the teams to the corporate sponsors but
I think also what it means is being very
honest about what's happening in Qatar
right now you know while we were going
to air I heard that a journalist
reportedly in Qatar wearing a rainbow
Flag t-shirt has been told to take off
his T-shirt it seems like there's a very
serious issue there and of course the
work that we predominantly work on which
is the labor rights of the people who
built the stadiums is still there those
workers haven't gone anywhere they still
are owed compensation for unpaid wages
in some cases deaths were there a
competition to their relatives for
deaths and other issues so it's a very
concrete thing we're certainly going to
be pushing on those issues so that FIFA
the sponsors but also Qatar are held
accountable for human rights violation
that they're responsible for
yeah Qatar would certainly like for us
not to be talking about this right now
right it's day two of the World Cup and
hardly anybody is talking about the
matches themselves will the Emirate
succeed in pushing the controversies to
the background or is this going to
overshadow the entire world cup
yeah it's you know it's a question when
you hear when you say that to me I feel
very sad hearing that because I love my
football like everyone else does I want
to celebrate the football and that it's
in the Middle East you know I'm not from
the Middle East my family is it is
Muslim my background so it's something
that should be a time to celebrate but
you're quite right I think there's human
rights issues have have completely
overshadowed the tournament because
let's face it there's a very serious
issues there but it's simple things you
know I mean if for example the countries
were to allow their guests in the
country to wear things like rainbow
Flags allow armbands that are very soft
reflections of the need to respect the
rights of everyone that will go a long
way to making people feel like they're
doing the right thing so I think in many
ways Qatar itself is to blame for this
situation and of course so is FIFA you
know we obviously heard from Infantino
the president of FIFA on Saturday giving
a really bizarre and in some ways very
insulting speech the thing that people
really need to understand about that
speech is it's effectively him signaling
to the cutteries that he won't put any
pressure on them to address very real
human rights issues the thing to really
also emphasize is Qatar is not a free
Society it is a absolute monarchy the
opportunities for leverage on on things
like human rights and social reform are
very few and far between this is
probably the most unprecedented time to
have those kind of changes FIFA is one
of the few entities on the planet that
can actually influence how Qatar
responds to Human Rights so for them to
surrender the way that they have
absolutely the torment is being
overshadowed by these issues but there's
very good reason for that and on top of
that still even now there is time for
things to shift but frankly that window
is narrowing by the moment by the second
and this event will be over in a month
you already hinted at those workers that
will still be there after the World Cup
is over it's early days of course but I
want to get your take on what you
believe will be the legacy of this World
Cup
yeah it's a really good question I you
know I've worked on Qatar now for 10
years I've worked in human rights for
much longer than that but I think that
already even I'm surprised at how much
that the hard work that has been done by
good stakeholders in Qatar good people
in the cutlery system is being
squandered by the points that I just
raised I do worry that the Legacy will
be one that those changes will be
actually overshadowed but the failure to
really grab the nettle take those things
further I also worried to be honest with
you that if we're seeing the kind of
stories coming out from Qatar already
now arm bads being taken off people with
rainbow shirts being up being asked to
take them off on day two of the
tournament then you know are there going
to be other things that make it really a
fake on plea that this will be a
tournament that will be probably the
most you know um uh controversial in
history and that's that's really sad to
me it's not a manner of being
anti-cutter or a pro cutter it's there
are over 2 million workers in Qatar
there are thousands of people from the
lgbti community in Qatar there are women
who face all sorts of risks in that
country this was such a golden
opportunity in a part of the world which
is a very rich wonderful part of the
world I've traveled through it a lot
it's a wonderful part of the world but
it has such human rights issues in their
challenges and again the opportunities
to to really have some human rights wins
are so few and far between that yes it's
really quite sad that this could be
overshadowed by the situation but our
job is to keep monitoring that situation
to make sure for example workers get the
compensation of their own we're tracking
down as many workers as we can we're
working with other human rights
organizations and of course we're always
open to speak to FIFA and Qatar and the
stakeholders about what they can do to
address these things but I think we've
been very clear respect everyone's human
rights respect their dignity so that we
can actually enjoy the football and not
be banging on and on about human rights
during the middle of this huge
tournament
Mustafa Cadre specialists in human
rights and labor rights thank you so
much for your time it was a pleasure
speaking to you tonight
thank you so much